allora il pilota qui appena mandato il
drone sull'albero quindi fine dei giochi
ciao ragazzi tornando a fare una gita
con la mia famiglia che ho appena preso
lavinia
stiamo andando presso il fiume treja a
fare un pic nic di famiglia so che è una
bellissima zona ma ragazzi sta arrivando
guglielmo con un drone nuovo di zecca
non vedo l'ora di provarla pronto essere
distrutto si vabbè un fronte stand di 15
euro quindi elicotterino come facevo io
ne ho comprati e decine strutte questo è
un attrezzo insomma un certo livello
stiamo arrivando
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi vi presento acquisto del
secolo il drone dj ai mavic mini è un
cronico deciso di comprare su amazon
perché mi è stato consigliato visto che
pesa 249 g è l'unico drone o almeno è
uno dei pochissimi i droni che si può
guidare senza il patentino vi faccio
subito a vedere che cosa c'è dentro
questa scatola contiene il drone ed il
telecomando un caricatore tre batterie
dei cavetti per gli agganci al telefono
insieme a un piccolo cacciavite e delle
ricche di ricambio a parte dal
presupposto che questo scherzetto per
quanto pazzesco e per quanto in realtà
economico rispetto a quelli che sono
intonare un pochino più professionali
costa comunque 500 euro 15 a me è un
ottimo regalo per chi viaggia e
appassionato di questo tipo di cose
senza contare che è facilissimo
facilissimo da usare da mettere in piedi
se volete avere maggiori informazioni vi
lascio il link di amazon qua sotto
perché la vi dicono tutto quanto
prendere una batteria in finale della
nella questo qui e va con delle micro sd
che in finale sempre più fico che la
batteria
chiudiamo premiamo una volta e poi
potremo premuto è pronto premiamo una
volta piero tenuto attacchiamo questo
qua facciamo passare sotto il cavo il
nostro controller e possiamo già farlo
volare a take off
tenete premuto e lui
[Musica]
avete la possibilità di prendere questo
tasto e far partire una registrazione a
una stabilità assurda è fermo e lì
immobile
a terra
i ragazzi nessuno mi sta pagando che fa
sta cosa che sia chiaro è che mi piace
proprio voglio provarlo avete una serie
caratteristica pazzesca perché ha un gps
quindi lui può tornare da lui quando si
perde geniale detto ciò direi di
provarlo in esterni partiamo con la
musica ti vedi e di
[Musica]
a
vaio
[Musica]
ora
nomi ma
[Musica]
chi troviamo ragazzi giulia come sempre
siamo in 40 ci ha fatto questo
biscottino lei fa e sempre queste torte
buonissime che sono grandi più o meno
così il mito di informarmi con la maglia
porta un bisturi per tagliarle in 47
festini identiche che cos'è
stiamo girando da un azzurro come no ma
li sapete dice che ha fatto amicizia con
una coccinella che non si stacca più la
lei non ce la faccio più su quelle
giornate in famiglia tutti insieme che
bello paten trovo in mezzo al delirio
gente la salta con le chitarre i cimbali
perché ti porti le chitarre un simbolo
al parco un bambino sta facendo il bagno
nel lago ma ci sono le sanguisughe i
tuoi genitori non meritano di alzarti
genitori questa così nella preso casa
sul boccino d'oro di bella non ti vuole
lasciare mai più ma è palo ferma mattia
gioca subito qualcosa all'enalotto ti
prego decine i numeri io e questo pone
abbiamo lo stesso arricchiere mi sembra
evidente fornaca xvi ho paura questo
pollo commesso congelato e sta cucinando
da 7 ore e non ha una bella faccia che
il nostro padre 52 un po da mangiare
ecco
buoni debba intorno agli altri se fai
canestro ti do 50 euro
no non male ma inciampato i tuoi soldi
si sono andati un po in appello e il
cavallino tieni cavallino cavallino a
parte qualche bello questo cavallino io
ma voi non devo conosciuti ancora
bagnato ma che sta succedendo ragazzi
presto bruce occhio che forti che ho
brooks e sta andando 6 sta dando ma ti
sei allenato le scarpe la palla che cosa
stai andando a fare cosa stai andando a
fare cileni mutande fammi capire se stai
cercando di andare là in quelle fratte
davanti a noi poi perché noi siamo stati
per sentirti problema guardava e
tranquilla nessuno ti sto fermo
lasciamo le ragazze loro privacy fai
giulia il tuo momento è la vini al tuo
momento questo lasciati un like se anche
voi avete fatto pipì una volta invita
mostra in un fiume o la pro cioè non è
carino da parte tua lo raggiungere gli
altri ti stiamo aspettando che fai ci
raggiunge diamo dai siamo pronti per il
torneo torneo fino in mezzo a sì
veramente cavani
i bambini altalene la palla finisce nel
recinto due degli asini ecco le nostre
eroine sono le tue mutande quelle che in
mano c'è quel filo interdentale sono
impariamo guadato il fiume per fare la
pipì non so se capita anche a voi
ma dopo un po che io faccio queste
uscite con la famiglia e tutti quanti
io odio tutti e voglio tornare a casa e
questo dopo un po in realtà e dopo un
ora siamo qui credo da tre ma sembrano
già sette giorni come quelli di samaras
non prende il telefono più niente poi
manco chiamare lei voglio andare a casa
e quel tipo di nucara partito a
pallavolo
perché
ragazzi c'è qualcuno in porta sfiga e
sta per piovere di ragazzi montati
lavorava la vita faccio farvi usa
giocate al lavoro per il mio sollazzo
sta lì da due secondi un bambino
guardavo avere bambina g
che cosa che vi fa ho ripreso tu vuoi
rubare altalena deprime sull'altalena ma
i bambini stanno lì da ore prima bambina
mia bolli data per scendere
la rete montata saper venire giù il
diluvio quindi torneremo domani
ma è sul muschio scivoloso bravo attacco
york
bravo senza bagnati 6 tipo rosso ma
cazzo suo telefono prima partita finita
e guglielmo è stato demolito
[Musica]
come stai
stop risponderti
[Applauso]
ecco le ore c'è una bambina vado a
salire niente ragazzi siamo una squadra
imbarazzante ci stanno sfondando la pena
sta guardando il vuoto
puoi dire qualcosa l'ultima cena
guardando il terrore è un blog solo di
droni
[Risate]
un ventilatore lo vorrei fare
allora il pilota qui appena mandato il
drone sull'albero quindi fine dei giochi
piange che bene nè un drone ha un nome
il nostro drone si chiama norberto
andiamo a prendere norberto dall'albero
mi sono appena tornati alla mente tutti
i ricordi dove schianta voi elicotterini
allora dov'è norberto norberto povero
norberto gratis abbiamo un eroe che sta
tentando di andare a salvare norberto
guglielmo con aria interrogativa ancora
continua indossare le scarpe o mia bella
penna noto che il mare ma perché ne sara
violi notte per margiotta incagliato
pure beinasco l'altro sprechi e poi
penna sull'albero no no
l'altro che quello mettiamoci sotto
elezioni
ma io casinò sta accadendo fabrizio è un
circo
[Applauso]
cos'ha da dire che se un imbarazzo
chiedo scusa a tutti quanti voi che
soprattutto ringraziare
eccolo non ci serve più adesso ok grazie
perché vediamo dopo grazie dichiarazioni
[Risate]
o la linea l'area e basca e mangiato già
abbastanza tra la gente ci furono
rotello cioè mangiare tua sorella
vado a prendere la macchina aspettami
qua a gomma come ci si sente ad aver
rischiato di distruggere il drone il
primo giorno cosa non l'hai fatto
apposta e lo so che non è fatto apposta
per o pochino di attenzione la prossima
volta
ragazzi tutto bene quel che finisce bene
il drone vivo seguite subito mettete su
un pollice in su per il e soprattutto le
[Musica]
questioni di immagine
fortunatamente ci sono alberi va bene
andiamo su un ragazzo bravo confermo
dice un albero